[Music]
[Applause]
uh Dave mcmenamin covers the NBA for the
mothership he's covering the nuggets and
the Lakers it'll be game four tonight at
8 30 Eastern on ESPN before we talk
about this series Dave if I said you
could have the career of Carmelo Anthony
or Christian Laettner
the entire basketball career Melo just
announced his retirement
I don't know if you can see the Jersey
behind my my shoulder there Dad I'm a
little biased I went to school with
Carmelo Anthony there's no way I would
ever pick uh Crystal later in this
scenario I'd have to recuse myself from
uh
answering that with uh an unbiased heart
there but um obviously
multiple championships for for Chris
later and Duke but Carmelo Anthony had
what a ride the best freshman season in
the history of NCAA tournament and he
follows her up with a multi-time Olympic
gold many medalist obviously all the
scoring accolades he had at the height
of his powers with the nuggets and the
Knicks in particular and uh yeah what a
what a career all right Carmelo Anthony
or Andre Iguodala
wow
Andre iguodala's best success was as a
role player on a championship team
obviously the finals MVP in 2015 is a
significant accomplishment but I don't
think Andre Iguodala both those players
again tremendous careers for both of
them they never reached the height of
basketball skill and I guess the weight
that is on one's shoulders has a star
yeah uh that Carmelo Anthony reached you
got a story from uh
Carmelo in college
uh it's the last time I saw him was uh
in late March the last home game ended
up being for Coach Jim behind against
Wake Forest and uh just everyone you
recognize as you get older how rare and
special something like that is and all
the dominoes that need to fall uh in
order for not just carmelon if they end
up at Syracuse at a time but Jerry
McNamara to be there and it came work to
be there and
um some of the great coaches on that
that team Troy Weaver and Mike Hopkins
uh who's going on both have gone on to
tremendous success in their own right I
I guess the beverage just sticks out we
are all in the green room after there's
a watch party the night before the Wake
Forest game
and Carmelo Anthony is pouring wine out
of a wine label that he owns
everyone is sharing in his life the last
time I shared a drink with him on campus
at Syracuse University we both had you
know Sharpie marker marks on our wrists
so we could get in to buy you know
dollar beers from from Chucks and so to
have that come full circle in 20 years
without a struck out that struck me all
right game tonight the Lakers are
favored by three I feel like they'll win
by two or lose by 20.
um
what is Denver doing so successfully
that the Lakers have a hard time
counteracting
first of all they are destroying the
Lakers on the offensive boards and
that's not just Nicole jokic it's their
front line of Aaron Gordon and Michael
Porter Jr uh constantly applying fresher
to the Lakers when it comes to
rebounding and you give this nuggets
team extra possessions they're smart
with it you know one of the easiest
shots in basketball is a three-pointer
off of an offensive rebound usually
you're catching it in Rhythm and you're
wide open and also the next thing I
would mention is the Nuggets three-point
shooting has been much better than the
Lakers and that's not a surprise because
the Lakers shooting really has been
something that's come and gone over the
entire season both free trade deadline
and post-trade deadline
but that said game one's a six-point
game game two is a five-point game game
three the Lakers have a lead in the
third in the fourth quarter I should say
until the Nuggets go on a 13-0 run in a
three-minute span in a blink of an eye
the thing's over
there are people within the Lakers
organization that I was speaking to over
the last 48 hours that certainly still
are holding on to hope so holding on to
belief
um looking to go into game four make
something happen extend the series and
you never know
like what uh the Joker said he's like
hey we gotta keep going they got LeBron
you know you you can't unlike the
Celtics the Celtics I don't think
respect the Miami Heat they maybe Jimmy
Butler but they don't respect The
Supporting Cast I I like what Joker said
hey you know we gotta keep going they
have LeBron here but this is a different
LeBron that we've seen
he's relying on the three and they're
making him work at the other end
um how much does he have like does he
have that 40 point game in him or the
potential for that now
I don't think that would be the Lakers
best recipe for Success
um thinking that that would be the way
they would extend this thing LeBron
pulls a 40-pointer out of a out of a hat
I mean he was tremendous in the closeout
game against the Golden State Warriors
where he went for 30 plus but that's the
only 30 plus playoff game he's had since
the 2020 bubble uh he's
defensive efforts and impact on Nicole
jokic in particular have been remarkable
it's not it's not like he's having a bad
Series in the overall sense
um but he is not the 40-point scorer he
once was and that's listen his peers are
retired Dwyane Wade is hosting uh a game
show Carmelo Anthony just uh hung it up
LeBron is still competing in the Western
Conference Finals
um that's no small feat just making that
statement but to expect him at 38 years
old 20 years into this thing to be the
40-point score I think you look to
number three Anthony Davis who scored 40
in game one to be that guy
yeah and then I wonder
you know is it worse to get swept in the
Western Conference Finals or you know
not make the playoffs or bow out in a
you know a playing game
well that goes to the LeBron MJ argument
that's been made for years well MJ's six
or six in the finals what about all the
years he didn't make the finals that man
yeah you know LeBron to get to the
finals 10 times is an accomplishment in
itself and I I I would think
playing competitive basketball is really
what is continuing to throw fuel on the
furnace inside of him to try to extend
this thing to year 21 to year 22 perhaps
beyond that and uh these games the more
he can get them this time of year the
more he's going to be motivated in
August and September to get his body
right for for tip-off of training camp
they're going to be able to keep Austin
Reeves
oh yes certainly uh they've these
restricted free agent he fits everything
in their culture that they'd want
um in terms of competitiveness in terms
of ability to play in the modern NBA uh
in terms of the The Pride factor that
he's basically a homegrown Talent
someone identified as an undrafted
player coming out of Oklahoma and it
could be a a number that seems pretty
big it could be like 20 million dollars
a year but when the new CBA kicks in
that number actually will seem pretty
amenable can you explain the Miami Heat
culture
the makeup that I think they're
undrafted players are averaging over 60
points in this series against Boston
how do you explain this
I mean you start with Pat Riley and you
filter down to very smart people like
Andy ellisberg have been there for
forever in the front office and Eric
Spoelstra and that's the Trump written
when it comes to
the Brain Trust and then they still have
standards that I don't think other teams
employ quite so often I mean they're
still making you do Fitness tests and
checking your body fat levels with like
pictures you know like that doesn't that
doesn't happen too often in uh modern
society
um even in the NBA yeah so I think you
start there and and then they recruit
and they identify players based on
competitive makeup and
um you know that doesn't necessarily
jump off the page in athleticism or
shooting percentages or all the other
metrics that were so accustomed to
judging players by uh you gotta really
kind of know your sport know the
psychology of it know the people in it
in order to succeed in that that manner
and obviously Jimmy Butler uh is the
prototypical heat athlete and all credit
to him on the court obviously
um you it it's so fun watching him play
because if you
are watching a Heat game they're down 12
with four minutes to go in the in the
fourth quarter oh it's Jimmy playing
okay they got a chance yeah they got a
chance and like that's what makes these
games worth watching well that's why
when ESPN came out with their analytics
and said that he'd had a three percent
chance you're not factoring in Jimmy
Butler you're not factoring in
experience you're not factoring in Eric
Spoelstra and uh is it now flipped is it
97 for the Miami Heat and three percent
or is it even three percent for the
Boston Celtics
I can't
um
yeah I guess it's higher than three
percent I give them a 10 shot I mean if
you get game four you go back to Boston
for game five yeah but you got to do
something that's never been done before
and you're doing it with this group who
they're they're just so inconsistent
I mean but we used to watch the NCAA
tournament Dan and the 16th theater
never beat a one seed and and now does
that seem like such a far-fetched idea
over after watching the 20 the last few
years I'm not so sure and now okay but
who has a better chance than the Celtics
to come back or the Lakers to come back
I would say the Lakers all those games
have been close they didn't lose by 30
points in a game three uh even though it
was I think 11 the final margin of game
three uh I would give the Lakers a
better chance I don't think either
team's gonna do it uh but if we're gonna
see one of the them pull it off and pick
the Lakers have fun tonight Dave thank
you again for joining us
anytime dad Dave mcmenamin covering the
uh NBA for the mothership 8 30 Eastern
game four tonight